you
all right 36 was that magic number
Dhamma arm okay I wish my clock let's
see
not until I make my first move oh this
pond is being hit already now watch out
for that sniper Bishop on b1 that deadly
bishop okay my opponent is saying the
stream is muted perfect okay I think
this I think it'd be pretty crazy to do
this move because this Bishop on C one
would be licking his chops and nobody
wants to see that not quite sure if that
even means okay this is the copycat
variation of some 960 position all right
I don't know if I want to copy that move
why don't I want to copy that move well
maybe I want to play my bishop here
first and then play d6 but I certainly
am I'm running in a direction where
there might be some tempos gained
against my bishop for example a bishop
d5 if III I always have to contend with
f4 or maybe d4 so so maybe who cares
maybe I still just do that let's do it
in yellow all right and now let's do
this this is a weakened square now
they're flying I wish they wouldn't fly
like that they're going too fast
how many gonna castle how would I kick
this bishop around wait let's cover this
square maybe let's do this and then I
could play Queen here therefore they are
officially flying
you know what i'ma do I'm gonna form a
fancy term I'm gonna form a fancy term
this guy is just rattling off one move
right after the other
let's do this this is a quark grip some
fancy term they're all for these squares
are defended let's let's get rid of that
light square Bishop and I could Castle
kingside
I'm gonna do that I forgot about that I
could have done that on the front we
both could have done that on our first
move its backup Knight here is gonna be
a pain huh maybe I should have just
killed him how do I get my light square
Bishop back active why is he going there
he wants to do this right hmm is that
what he wants to do okay I I need to
just I already feel like I need to move
instantly okay I'm just gonna do this
we're castle and opposite sides I'm
hoping for maybe one day an attack like
pawn takes I was thinking I could move
my rook here how am I gonna do that all
right
let's kick this night away I want to get
this bish up let's take here and maybe
there's some checks here this night is
not gonna bother me anytime soon I don't
think he can maybe bother me by getting
into g5 uh I want to keep these squares
controlled I want to keep the knight out
if you place two d3 this pond rules him
out oh no no no no no let's throw in
this check he has to go over here let's
open up the position two minutes if you
like my opponent's going too fast try to
put pressure on me and he is a four
takes rook a 2
this is gonna be a problem let's keep
pushing I have this square covered pawn
takes my bishop is invited I could have
also taken this pawn but I just want to
I can still take this pawn let's take
here with check this is matin - if Fon
takes rook check queen bee - game over
and that's it that's it queen bee - is
lights out let's go back good game this
um
it shouldn't have happened like that
there's no way I think there was - too
much too much speed going on in the the
Fischer random game let's go back to the
history let me see you have the knight
retreat there was an there was a more
aggressive move for that night where was
that position again okay so from your
perspective yeah okay so this is my
first quick assessment right what's
unprotected these guys and he was hit
immediately Bishop takes his already a
threat on each seven so this was all
pretty pretty good on both sides
I like the e3 move to get enough for
with tempo maybe actually here's another
one probably back up keep that bish up
and then kick my knight away that might
have been another one alright it's it's
not apparent how this Bishop is going to
maybe hurt you someday and he didn't in
the game but this was my main point
right here instead of Knight their
forward that night h5 move I'm in
trouble I believe right if I can't
maintain my Bishop on this diagonal why
am i saying in trouble Knight h5 the
fish up here this Knight moves and then
what's happening for town c7
d six pressure and the main one g7 I
think Knight h5 was really gonna was
really gonna bother me that your pieces
are really well set up yeah I don't know
Knight age five I was I think I'm really
in some hot water because it's not it's
not just about the pressure here it's
clearing the way for this pun which is
what you did in the game and it's
there's two pieces two minor pieces and
then eventually a major piece that are
directly or indirectly putting pressure
on g7 and I feel like it's gonna
collapse yeah nine age five I'm pretty
sure okay but he retreated so it gave me
some breathing space so he did a little
dance h1 to f2 and that's the other
thing right this cost time at a moment
where that's the most important factor
since we're at a castle on opposite
sides time is super super key so that
gave me time to do something over here
and that guy got rolling your night out
kicked back you're without one less
defender and now here comes the wild ape
on some checks this is maybe now too
fast for you to deal with I will be
getting the first well you already have
a half-open file but this is a pretty
serious entry point on a two
now I still have two pawns on their home
squares to cover my king
I think I'm simply just faster at this
point and well I have the other def for
move item that f4 pon I could have taken
but this is just too fast Knight h5 is
really my main suggestion I should even
go one step further because how could I
have done better if this knight h5 was
going to be so good how did I get myself
into this position maybe it was a poor
choice
like I was saying right here maybe I was
saying I didn't want to play this
copycat game maybe I want to do this
I was also pointing out while I do run
the risk of these III f4 ideas I don't
know maybe this was a poor choice to
bring my bishop out here I just run into
some tempo gaining moves as it did
happen in the game with each with f4 and
then it could have happened with the
knight h5 so maybe it is at this point I
should have done something different
maybe I should still should have gone
with this b6 Bishop here yeah I don't
know I I think this was a poor choice by
me I probably should have done b6 maybe
maybe castled I'm not sure okay
I'm not sure really what else to add
other than good game
fortunately my name was on e one